bon
on est à 600 kilomètres d'un sna ça fait
loin par exemple le fait
reconnaît le david on est perdus aux
tournées ici mais non c'est ici je te
dis pas que je sois pas aussi stupide
c'était un accident s'est avancé devant
la voiture on voudrait surtout pas que
les policiers reviennent et qui se met à
nous poser des tas de questions je
dérape les jours que tu es monté dans
une voiture avec un homme ivre ce qui
fait une complice ils accomplissent d'un
homme ivre depuis un bon moment
puisque tu comptes bouder tout le week
end on trouve ainsi des musées c'est pas
un crime de s'amuser du cerf je suppose
que je pourrais faire un effort
c'est un art vous le dit
est-ce qu'il a parlé d'argent non il
souhaite que vous rentriez avec eux pour
enterrer le garçon c'est la coutume dans
leur région
beaucoup de gens disparaissent il se
volatilise
[Musique]
pas d'accord
vous avez fait quoi avec ces cartes
tous les intérêts
ils n'ont pas juste de renverser et lui
ont roulé dessus
être même plus de deux fois comment ils
appellent ça dans votre pays chine
écrasé
vous ne pouviez pas fuir nez vous cacher
que ça tu as traversé l'esprit richard
qui pourraient avoir des attentions
beaucoup plus sinistres que ce que tu
imagines
j'avais un mari est fait et toi aussi
pourquoi avez vous accepté de venir ici
[Musique]